I wasn't pregnant in that specific you
weren't pregnant but yeah beam
Wonderwoman is hard enough as it is so
we were stunned when we found out that
you were actually pregnant while filming
Justice League gal gadot you bring a
whole new meaning to the term superhero
you were barely showing in Justice
League but you were a whopping five
months pregnant while filming Wonder
Woman reshoots and I just had a funny
costume
we cut a big triangle and painted green
this way they could use visual effects
to flatten out your baby bump time to
female stars have had to hide their
pregnancies while on set which isn't the
easiest thing to do producers found
clever ways to hide their leading lady's
pregnant bellies from hiding their
midsections behind props to dressing
them in oversized sweaters to creating
new storylines in which their characters
were actually pregnant watch until the
end to find out which popular sitcom had
to hide not one but two pregnancies at
the same time Julie Bowman on Modern
Family one of the best TV shows on ABC
is hands-down Modern Family the hit TV
series took the world by storm in 2009
but filming the show's pilot episode
would be a lot more challenging than
directors intended it to be and that's
because Julie Bowman who plays Claire
Dunphy was pregnant with twins Modern
Family executives had their work cut out
for them when casting the lead roles for
the show they wanted to find the perfect
actors and they knew that Julie was the
ideal candidate to play Phil Dunphy's
eccentric wife problem was she was super
pregnant so to hide her huge baby bump
Claire was made to cover up her
midsection with pillows laundry baskets
and cereal boxes producers dressed her
in over sized clothing and everything
went according to plan he really
couldn't tell that Julie was weeks away
from delivering twins Anna Paquin on
True Blood turns out being pregnant with
twins isn't that uncommon especially for
celebrities much like Julie Bowman Anna
Paquin was pregnant with twins while
filming season five of True Blood she
wasn't just a little pregnant though she
was six months pregnant Anna who
portrayed Sookie Stackhouse is married
to her True Blood co-star Stephen Moyer
in her first
and they were super excited to welcome
their twins Charlie and poppy into the
world but before they could do that they
had to continue filming like nothing was
out of the ordinary and producers came
up with some super clever ways to hide
Sookie stomach while Sookie would
usually wear daring outfits to bed she
opted for loose PJs and if she wasn't
hiding behind a desk a car or a book
Sookie was showcased hugging a pillow
but Anna and Steven weren't the only
True Blood co-stars to get pregnant with
twins did you know that Sam Chimel who
played Sam Merlotte on the show also has
a set of twins what are the odds of that
Kelly Rutherford on Gossip Girl
Callie Rutherford has made a name for
herself as one of the most dramatic
actresses of all time she starred in TV
dramas like Melrose Place Gossip Girl as
van der Woodsen's sure more than you
could possibly imagine and Pretty Little
Liars the perfectionist but did you know
that Kelly was actually pregnant while
filming the second season of Gossip Girl
that's right back in 2008 kelly was
expecting so producers had to get a
little creative
while some shows will choose to create a
pregnancy storyline for their characters
a third child just wasn't in the works
for Lily van der Woodsen so she was made
to cover up her baby bump in some of the
most ridiculous ways instead of wearing
tight-fitting clothing Lily was shown
wearing large coats scarves and gowns in
some cases Lily would be given huge hand
bags and made to hold them over her
belly and when they ran out of options
Lily was given a newspaper as camouflage
the whole ordeal was pretty hilarious
but in the end many viewers never once
suspected that she may be pregnant in
real life Zooey Deschanel on new girl if
you loved Zooey Deschanel you probably
made it a point to binge watch every
episode of new girl yeah of course but
did you notice that Zoe was actually
pregnant while filming season five of
the show instead of focusing on the plot
around Zoe's baby bump the show's
writers cooked up one of the wackiest
storylines of all time
Zooey who plays Jess was summoned for
jury duty this way Zooey could hide her
pregnant belly behind the jurors bench
when that got boring
Zooey left the show for a total of seven
episodes and showrunners spiced things
up by adding Megan Fox to the casting
list
Megan played the role of Regan a woman
who briefly moved into the guys
apartment
but even before jess was sequestered
showrunners crafted up a way to hide her
pregnancy jess was made to take a bad
fall down the stairs
which resulted in her breaking a few
bones and being bedridden once in her
bed Zoey could hide her belly under a
pile of blankets lisa kudrow and
courtney cox on friends earlier we
mentioned that there was a sitcom that
had to hide not one but two pregnancies
but we're not talking about friends sure
both Lisa and Courtney got pregnant
while filming the show but their
pregnancies didn't happen at the same
time stay tuned to find out which show
his leading ladies got pregnant during
the very same season but first let's
talk about friends we all know how
Phoebe agreed to be a surrogate mother
of her brother's triplets
well she didn't know it would be
triplets at the time but that's beside
the point
but did you know that Lisa Kudrow was
pregnant for real that's right she
wasn't acting John you're being preggers
no piece of cake okay and in season 10
it was Courtney's turn to get pregnant
however the writers couldn't work her
pregnancy into the storyline because at
this point Monica and Chandler were in
the process of adopting a child because
they couldn't conceive on their own
while Lisa didn't have to hide her baby
bump
Monica covered hers up by wearing baggy
shirts are you subscribed to the things
yet if not what are you waiting for
crash that big red subscribe button and
click that Bell to be notified whenever
we post a new video if you love keeping
up with your favorite celebs TV shows
and movies you'll love our Channel go
into your YouTube settings and turn on
notifications if you're watching on your
mobile now back to on-set pregnancies
Melissa Fumero on Brooklyn nine-nine if
you're a fan of Brooklyn nine-nine then
you know that Jake and Amy are total
couple goals but you should also know
that Amy and Jake aren't exactly ready
to be parents yet they've thought about
it but the showrunners didn't want to
rush the couple's storyline so when
Melissa Fumero who plays Amy revealed
that she was pregnant show owners had to
think outside the box and that wasn't a
problem considering that the entire show
takes place outside of the box instead
of trying to hide Melissa's belly by
using crafty camera tricks writers used
Melissa's predicament as fuel look
pregnant I mean
they created an interesting twist that
placed Amy in a woman's prison
Amy was asked to go undercover in a
woman's prison and to make herself look
unthreatening Amy pretended to be
pregnant this storyline allowed Amy to
prance around with her pregnant belly in
full view still some viewers had no idea
that melissa was pregnant in real life
did you know melissa was actually
pregnant tell us in the comments Kerry
Washington on scandal
Kerry Washington portrayed Olivia Pope
on the hit TV series scandal from 2012
to 2018 but in 2014 Kerry would face one
of the biggest challenges of her acting
career Kerry who is the leading lady of
the series announced that she was
pregnant for the very first time but
since a pregnancy didn't make sense for
Olivia's storyline on the show
showrunners decided to hide Kerry's
pregnancy from their viewers hiding her
pregnancy wasn't a hard thing to do
producers use the usual tricks which
consisted of hiding her belly behind
oversized handbags lampshades and
folders however Kerry experienced some
hardships of her own during her
pregnancy
the actress opened up about how
difficult it was for her to act while
pregnant her body was going through so
many changes and focusing on her acting
duties proved to be most challenging
thankfully the show's writer the one and
only Shonda Rhimes had already planned
to air a shorter season so everything
worked out perfectly for Kerry Ellen
Pompeo on Grey's Anatomy
Grey's Anatomy is one of the
longest-running TV series in America and
it would be nothing without its amazing
writer Shonda Rhimes and its leading
lady Ellen Pompeo Allen has portrayed
dr. Meredith Grey for a total of 16
seasons she spent a good portion of her
life walking and Meredith shoes my
medical license should not be in this
man's hands he is dangerous but in
season six Allen decided to start a
family of her own
and since Allen's character wasn't rides
get pregnant showrunners decided to hide
her pregnant belly they accomplished
this by dressing Meredith in large
surgical gowns and primarily filming her
from the chest and shoulders up once
Ellen gave birth the show's writers
wanted to make sure that the new mom
would have plenty of time to adjust so
they gave her a total of four weeks off
and slowly reintroduced her into the
series Amy Poehler on Parks and
Recreation Amy Poehler is a famed
who has supplied us with entertainment
since she first stepped onto the scene
in the late 1990s she got her start on
Saturday Night Live before starring in
her very own TV series operation soaring
Falcon is in its final stages
Parks and Recreation was a total hit it
aired from 2009 to 2015 and Amy's
character Leslie Knope is still by far
one of the most well written characters
of all time she's known for her
eccentric ways and her heart to love
personality but did you know that amy
was pregnant while filming the second
half of season two well neither did we
until now producers chose against
writing Amy's pregnancy into the series
they managed to keep Leslie behind her
desk for as long as possible
then the show took an extended hiatus to
give Amy a well-deserved break Alyson
Hannigan and Cobie Smulders on How I Met
Your Mother
heidi and when pregnancy is hard enough
as it is but hiding - is a whole other
ballgame you might be surprised to find
out that both Alyson Hannigan and Cobie
Smulders were pregnant while filming
season four of How I Met Your Mother
Allison who plays Lily on the show was
the first to announce her pregnancy and
then soon after Cobie who played Robin
also spilled the beans the leading
ladies of the show hid their pregnancies
by wearing loose clothing they also made
it a point to hold large objects over
their midsections in the end showrunners
chose to omit ålesund and Kobes
pregnancies from the script their
characters just weren't ready to become
parents funny enough Lily's pregnant
belly was showcased in a flashback scene
in the episode titled the possible
and then when Alison disappeared from
the show after hearing Barney's super
dirty joke and we didn't see Lily for
four weeks she was actually on maternity
leave
both Alison and Coby were thrilled to go
through their first pregnancies together
and that's a wrap on the 10 stars who
had to hide their pregnancies on set
were you shocked to find out that some
of these leading ladies were pregnant in
real life sound off in the comments
thanks for watching the things don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll see you next time